I saw you on curb I was on curb what was
that it was amazing how does that happen
I've auditioned for every lesbian part
there is here in mankind okay when you
want to Les now this is pre probably two
or three years ago because things have
changed and being less is just too
normal now yeah so when in auditioned
you go back then you audition with Larry
himself he's curious about that yeah oh
my God yes what's it like when you're
actually filming curb though because
it's you hear all these stories about it
and then you watch it it just seems like
you know it's a lot of improv right it's
all improv yeah it was literally all so
they don't give you any lines at all
there's no script what they gave is like
a bullet points we need to get you need
to start here you need to end here okay
so you you go in and you're gonna give
them a haircut and he's going to talk to
you and you need to then end it and
leave so that's what we need you to do I
think we shot each thing three times so
the first time you do it then they
extract those parts that they liked can
you hit that again then you go back and
do it again and then it was like we
didn't like that thing you did yeah so
now do it that that don't do that and
then whatever the [__] that seems harder
than just having a script and being like
I just have to hit these lines for me I
like it yeah even though it's
nerve-wracking and it's when you're out
of your element and all of these people
are so I mean it's like Larry David and
JB Smoove walked in and I was like oh my
God like this is crazy and I'm and it's
hard it is stressful but I do like doing
that I feel like it's easier for me than
doing a script I mean she doesn't even
prepare like in general so an improv
audition is fantastic for her because
I'll be like driving her to an audition
where she has to like um she's like a
lesbian fire fire woman who a fight gets
stuck in like under some Rubble with a
man and has to be like come on man you
can make it and then she won't she'll be
like right outside the door and late
yeah late to that audition and she's
like oh wait oh okay and I'm like you
didn't even know you had to rescue
someone you have to go and do a drama
scene yeah yeah I'm never prepared
because I don't want to be I'm annoyed
I'm annoyed that's how entitled I am I'm
annoyed